on louvre maintenant une page découverte
dans ce set 8 sport notre journaliste
marc il n 'ya piché au nous a rejoint
sur ce plateau bonsoir alors marylène
nous présentera chaque mois des sports
méconnus
ce soir marylène vous allez vous faire
découvrir une discipline le krav maga
alors j'ai bien dit discipline énonce
sport calloch krav maga
c'est pas facile à dire n'est pas un
sport effectivement michael le krav maga
est une méthode d'atteinte défensive qui
nous vient directement des forces
militaires israéliennes
il n'y a pas de règles pas de respect de
l'adversaire il s'agit d'apprendre à
répondre à une attaque eric salem sait
de quoi il parle cet ancien des unités
spéciales d'intervention de la
gendarmerie a décidé d'enseigner ces
techniques de défense au civil en créant
son école énergie défense face à une
agression au couteau
on a pu rencontrer dans la capitale et
ailleurs on va essayer de se sortir de
là a une âme une défense une attaque qui
va être proportionnelle à la propre à
pâques on est en train de subir
donc effectivement sur la une attaque au
couteau bon bah on va parler bonbons par
une attaque au couteau évidemment mais
on va être on va donner les moyens
d'être est très efficace et c'est ouvert
à tout le monde alors sur le principe
oui merci
wells le principe parce que
l'instructeur se réserve le droit de
vous demander votre casier judiciaire
s'il vous sous peine de venir pour de
mauvaises raisons
si au départ beaucoup d'hommes
s'inscrivaient pour se défouler
aujourd'hui l'école comprend
pratiquement 50% de femmes nathalie
salem s'occupe des cours réservé aux
fans
objectif prendre confiance en soi c'est
pas que de la self défense c'est à dire
contre attaque
d'accord
pour justement se sortir d'une situation
il faut oser contre-attaqué donc faut
avoir une certaine confiance en soi pour
jusqu'à mans contre attaque et on
apprend à frapper alors que je sais pas
rayonné et vous avez justement essayer
marylène et je crois que vous êtes
plutôt bien débrouillé jesse may montré
trois gestes de base pour me dégager
d'un agresseur et vous allez voir qu'en
plus il ne m'a pas ménagé la main qui a
été saisie va venir par dessous est tout
simplement avec l'autre main
[Musique]
serons nous étrangle walesa vous allez
vouloir respirer même donc exact et
simultanément les frapper ok ça qu'on
est là on repoussait mois on va très
bien poussé poussé à l'est
[Musique]
alors là se maintenir sauter dans le
train pour repartir de leur côté fait
des choix les cours de maths en fait ils
te repas
[Musique]
et si vous voulez vous y mettre vous
aussi émergé défense propose des cours
mixtes aux sportifs sporting de
guyancourt
vous pouvez également prendre des cours
particuliers plusieurs renseignements
sur leur site internet qu'ils
s'affichent justement en bas de l'écran
on y réfléchira à deux fois avant de
faire des blagues en rédaction en tout
cas marylène merci beaucoup on vous
retrouvera le mois prochain sur ceux à
7,8 sport